this box contains an entire opticians
workshop Martine Alford has packed it
with the equipment needed to make a pair
of glasses the device for bending the
wire is the heart of his invention
within days
anyone can learn to make and fit glasses
the aim is for local people in
developing countries to produce the
glasses themselves it's mainly about the
cost it can't cost more than a dollar so
that people who have just a dollar a day
to live on can afford it it also has to
be robust this is hypoallergenic rust
proof spring steel wire I can bend it
without breaking the glasses I could
even sit on it and it wouldn't break the
lens grinder is the only part that needs
electricity but it can also be powered
by a car battery
many African villages have no
electricity for the past 18 months
Monte elf mode has been training teams
they take the opticians kit to villages
the project got off to a good start in
Uganda where they equipped 500 people
with glasses in just two weeks
children who now have a chance to
succeed in school and grown-ups whose
livelihoods depend on a pair of glasses
a typical case was this woman she was
fifty years old she was a seamstress but
could no longer thread her needle so she
didn't have any work anymore usually
five six seven people in the family
depend on her income so she was happy to
get a pair of glasses for a dollar so
she could go back to work knocking boxes
of old glasses this is how aid
organizations have tried to help people
with poor eyesight but it's almost
impossible to find a match and refitting
frames with new lenses is expensive
off-note is trying an alternative with
his team
he's got ready-made polycarbonate lenses
that range from minus six to plus six
diopters the person tries it out they
close one eye and hold the different
lenses in front of the other until they
find the one that corrects their vision
best when they've done that for both
eyes they get the glasses that suits the
size of their face from the price of a
dollar
Levin offered health finally the frames
are customized with beads Martin off
moots idea has received several awards
his goal is to help everyone on the
planet have the eyesight they need